yeah you did  moments after twelve-year-old  singer-songwriter grace van der waals  scored a million dollars for winning the  talent competition  she told ET how she plans to spend her  fortune I want to go on treehouse  masters and get a sick treehouse zipline  bridges everything well lucky for grace  someone very important heard what she  said  treehouse masters host Pete Nelson I'm  thrilled to think that you mentioned you  want to have a treehouse built I mean  seriously  because we could do that we could be at  your house tomorrow bridges zip lines  the whole thing congratulations and call  me right we imagine Grace's reaction to  the offer went a little something like  this  he could tear the joy right the  songstress replied to Pete on Twitter  retweeting his video and gushing in the  caption quote oh my god calling calling  calling hashtag miracles do happen